[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney
best-selling
author and host of the ever popular dr
john dolone
podcast is my co-host today you can talk
directly to him the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five five if you didn't know he talks
about life and anxiety and boundaries
and mental health and those kinds of
things
relationship issues so we'll talk about
that we'll talk about your money we'll
talk about your life when we're gonna do
it all right in front of you
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five starting off
this hour
is caitlin in houston texas hey caitlin
what's up in your world
hey dave and john thanks for taking my
call sure
how can we help hey um so my fiance and
i were due to get married in about two
weeks
and um i'm doing our first in september
um
my question is about prenup um i've
heard you talk about them previously but
not as it relates to a business
and he's brought it up once before i
explained to him
why i don't like them and i actually
sent him a podcast you did on it
and apparently he understood from there
and the subject was
dropped but he's brought it up again and
he wants his business land
money he's acquired to this point all in
the prenup
so i i i don't know what to tell him or
how to help him
understand my perspective or maybe i'm
wrong about businesses in a prenup
um he had a previous business partner go
through a divorce and the wife tried to
take part of the business so
i think that's part of his concern
that i don't know what to tell him or
how to go
what's he making what's he make on this
business
um he makes he has a 50 50 partner and
he makes about
67 000 a year okay
whoopty yeah yeah i was gonna say high
five man
yeah that's awesome but i mean he
doesn't make 680 000 a year
so um
i i have a lot of thoughts
um and most of them are too mean to say
out loud
without filtering them so um and it's
hard for me to be quiet
because i've got a lot of mean thoughts
in my head well you you go first
hey caitlin i don't like here's me and
john here we go i'm gonna go nice i
don't like prenups i don't
like them it feels like you're walking
into something
that there should not be an exit
strategy for with
at least a crack in the door or a toe
out the door unless you've got some
really complex situations
i just don't like him and i get that
he's seen somebody get burned that makes
sense to me what i don't like is
you guys sat down and had this
conversation you talked about it
you made peace with it and then two
weeks out
he circled back and that feels like a
move to me that feels like a a move that
lacks integrity yeah like this
discussion should i had before we made a
baby
and it sounds like you did have it right
and this discussion should have been had
before we were two weeks from
yeah marriage is this is right
previously he just
i i basically i said no and he and i
and he agreed with the agreed with our
stance on the podcast so our stance on
the podcast is what john is saying
okay and i'll repeat what i probably
said then because it's what i say every
time i get this question okay
if everything is fairly equal and this
is fairly equal
uh i would not marry someone that
required a prenup
because you are planning your failure
you're planning your failure and there's
he loves his business his
half of his business more than you he's
more worried about his business partner
than you and that's just
he he didn't mean to say that but this
action says that
and so no no now the only and i used to
when i first started this and you heard
this on that podcast probably
because i almost always say this i used
to say no prenups ever the only time i
say a prenup is a good idea
is in extreme situation that's why i
asked about the size of the business
if he's making a million dollars a year
on this business and they own 20 million
worth of property and you got nothing
yeah that's an extreme situation and
that would warrant
the differentiation is a the difference
is a extreme situation and
even then i'm probably not 50 of the
prenup is for the actual marriage
but 50 of it is for both of your crazy
relatives
because uncle crazy as a june bug shows
up and decides he wants
your uncle crazy june bug decides he
wants a piece of your husband's business
that was there before you were
or uncle junebug showed up and uh and
you can just throw up your hands and go
i can't help you i got a prenup and so
it keeps the weirdness of your extended
family in line
and all extended family has weirdness
it's just every family
so that's it's good in extreme
situations this is not extreme enough
this has to do with
he was wounded by the other deal and
he's extrapolating that into your new
marriage and that
is not good medicine right
here's my concern for you this leaves
you really exposed either way right
because now you're having to either go
into a marriage and sign a piece of
paper that you don't feel comfortable
marrying
which is going to put a wedge between
you and this guy that you are tethering
yourself to for the rest of your life
or you're going to be a single mom here
in september
right yeah so he's put you in an
impossible situation
and that's why even beyond the prenup
i'll even go as far to say i get that
he's been burned and he's been hurt
before
and that's a scar fresh on his soul i
get that cool
i don't like that he waits till two that
feels like a move to me and that feels
like somebody that's gonna pull move
after move after move on you here in the
future
and even if he wasn't meaningful meaning
to do that and was manipulative right
he has unbelievable bad timing right
yeah yeah at a minimum yeah that's
giving him the benefit of the doubt
i mean you know you you you settle this
before we make babies before we get
engaged right
and hey here's here's the bigger thing
dave i
know there's millions of people that are
going to hear this and say that's stupid
that is stupid you got to protect
yourself if they say that they're stupid
i wasn't going to say that but here's
what i was going to say
if that's your first response then don't
get married yeah yeah don't get married
let me give you a weird the weirdest one
i ever had was a lady called and said
uh my fiance has a classic 1968 mustang
that's worth 140 000 dollars that he
built frame up and he wants a prenup to
protect
that and uh papa dave said don't marry
him
yep what don't marry him he loves this
stupid car
more than you that's right don't marry
him if it's my daughter i'd run that guy
off with
a gun right no do not marry him
this is not marriage material he has his
priorities
all screwed up if you love a car
more than you love your fiance you are
not marriage material
and it will move over time that car will
become a boat which will become a house
which will become
a my kids go into this college and
nobody else it will become a thing it
has to be i'll take a bullet for you
it's the only
shot you've got i'm making it through a
marriage yeah because there is you've
got to
you got to burn all the boats man
because which is hard yeah it's
everybody's going to have a moment where
you go i'm done with you i'm out
i'm out and if you say you haven't had
that then you haven't been married and
you're lying and then you got to run
before you're lying you got to run to
the shore and realize oh i don't have
any bugs oh god
yeah there's nowhere to go i got no i
can't drive off of my classic car
because again you know
and so yeah you got to make it work i
want somebody that will look at my
daughter
and my son and say i'll set that car on
fire for you
yeah that's the guy that's going to sit
at my kitchen table yeah right and this
business
is how i make a living and i love my
business and i love being in business
but it doesn't even show up on the same
spectrum oh welcome i love it
now play that one back for bubba this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and 6 gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to feartalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
well we decided with the ramsey research
team
that we wanted to learn not from the
timeshare industry
and not from the people who hate the
timeshare industry
but from you what you think
of your timeshare because there's all
these surveys out there and i'm calling
uh bogus on these surveys uh about the
time shares
well at least on there's one done by the
time share business this is 87 percent
of people love their time share there's
one
done by uh the uh the university
of florida i believe it was it said uh
central florida i believe did it said 87
people hate their time sure so that was
probably more credible
right i did a survey of husbands in my
home who think they're incredible and it
was a 100
response they really are doing a great
job four out of five dentists
who used the yeah too but yeah but the
uh anyway so we're gonna do
a time share uh piece we're gonna do
some research to see what you guys think
so
we're putting it out there we're gonna
do it to the public and and we're
you know using our normal research
procedure but we're also going to ask
you guys you hear me talking about time
shares
i want to hear from you are you a
current time share owner are you a
former
timeshare owner the new survey we want
to know your thoughts your opinions
and your experience with timeshares so
if you want to participate in the
research in the survey and tell us your
thoughts
um notice i'm not telling you what to
say but we'd love to have you
call i mean we know what you're going to
say because you're listeners but anyway
but uh yeah it'll work you know going to
look at that as a part of the research
text
timeshare 233 789
that's timeshare one word 233789
it might be really interesting to have
some of those um
issues that are exposed in that research
turned over to some of the
state legislatures that regulate these
businesses i wonder what would happen
then
yeah i would love to see well they need
their constituents to reach out and say
hey we're tired of being trapped by this
yeah and it could be
it could be that you know this research
shows that their constituents are being
screwed and yeah
that maybe they're maybe they get tired
i don't know you never know you just
never know
data man has a way of humbling us all
right data data is real michael's in
phoenix arizona hey michael how are you
i'm good dave uh thank you so much for
taking my call you and dr john
absolutely how can we help well
so uh i we moved my wife and i moved to
uh actually to nevada uh las vegas area
back in september thought she needed to
be in a bigger city
for her work i was commuting close to
two hours for my work
obviously uh kova changed everything
she's now able to work solely from home
pretty much with very little travel so
we decided to move closer to my job so
that i could actually be
part of my family um we we had several
months left on the lease we worked it
out with uh
we asked our landlord hey if we get
someone else in here to take over this
can we get out
he said absolutely uh then he listed the
property for 400
more than we were paying we thought we
had a someone else lined up that fell
through
but we went ahead and made the move to
arizona anyway
to cut out that commute and so now uh
the lease actually ends on august 10th
we're already in a new place in arizona
um and so we're just trying to figure
out what the best thing is to do with
this situation at this point
the deal the deal was that you if you
could re-rent it that he would let you
out but it didn't re-rent
it it it has not re-rented as of as of
now and
so you're not out so you're in that sure
that's the deal you made right
right and so i'm wondering it's causing
a lot of stress and anxiety for us and i
don't know if it's better just to
finish pay out the rest of it yeah
better to hold on and hope he does
well that's your deal well i know i
wouldn't finish paying it i'd pay it out
monthly
okay you have right do it the first of
the month i would pay it at the first of
the month i wouldn't pay it in advance
because he might rent it and so if you
pay
um well i guess july is coming up and
then you've only got august 10th so
you've got a partial due august first
right
right but even that might be even that
might be forgiven if he rents it august
1st
and and i guess with my question too is
is this something that i need to like
have a conversation with him about
i think that he's overpriced the market
and he doesn't really care because
i mean he's he's got us paying the
revenue
yeah and that's that's exactly what we
kind of
which if i'm in his shoes august 10th is
approaching quickly and i'm going to
price it appropriately so that i have a
tenant in there
august 1st so i don't skip a beat even
if i lose 10 days on you but prior to
that he was just fishing for a bottle
fishing for a nut to get somebody to
come in high
right right yeah i agree that i agree
that he didn't necessarily do you fair
uh whether it was intentional or not but
it is the deal you made
and you didn't you know you didn't save
any on the rent but yeah i would just
pay him july 1st and pay him uh 10 days
on august the 1st
and just be in communication with him
and say you know by the way are you
going to drop this so you can get it
rented and get me out because it seems
like you're high
and my guess is if y'all got the money
the anxiety you feel
is that you're walking around all day
thinking i should be doing something i
should be doing something i'm getting
ripped off i'm getting just let it be
man pay the written and move on
and you're going to feel some peace in
your life
all right well that is great advice
thank you it's annoying
but by the way michael you didn't do
anything wrong you did this properly you
did
if you would have called me and asked me
in advance what to do with it i would
have told you
to do exactly what you did except i
think you didn't get the agreement in
writing
and you should have gotten that but
other than that i think you did a good
deal here you use good
decision making skills it just didn't
work out you didn't get out of the lease
because they didn't rent it yeah and you
know you might have
you know on the front end stated that
you're going to you know
we got to list the thing at market value
and let's establish market value but
you don't get to tell the guy what he
rents his house for that's his house
so that's that's part of the problem you
learned a lesson next time that you move
you'll never make this mistake again
and you'll figure it out and you'll go
from there yeah you don't move before or
you
are you are you get something right you
plan on eating it and
uh but you did you did the you you
approached this the correct way i do
want to tell you that i don't think you
messed up i don't think it was a mistake
i think it just didn't work out
john is in cedar rapids john how are you
doing well hope you're making it a great
day we are sir how about you
doing quite well thank you how can we
help
so uh me and my wife have about
fifteen thousand fifteen and a half
thousand dollars in student loans that
have
been in default for quite some time and
i've got it on top of that and about
eleven hundred and seventeen dollars in
medical debt
and we have been working on baby step
one and we have amassed about
23 000 in savings
and the biggest problem we've been
having is we've not been managed to
communicate with
some of the student loan collectors
they're not taking our calls they're not
answering our letters
uh same thing with the medical debt and
my
free legal service that includes debt
negotiation and debt
and debt assistance with it with a
lawyer
and my question is i've got the money
and i won't be
i won't be beating you too far into our
emergency savings
so that we can pay this all off and be
debt-free in one go
should we be should we end should we a
uh be using the lawyer to take care of
that and also looking at potentially
negotiating down that debt
uh but still having it be paid in full
uh and b uh uh i want to be debt free so
i want to
be done with the student loans
regardless of the fact that it's zero
interest till september
yeah you need to write the checks and be
done you just got to find somebody to
write them to and find somebody to get
to get agreement on what the amount is
because
all you've got is an estimate yep and i
want
i want payoff letters yeah so that i can
literally have cashier's checks cut
and sent and be done with it exactly so
the
uh medical debt came from well here's
the thing you can you can turn it over
you says prepaid legal or somebody like
that
yeah it's well it's uh work my work pays
for my employer pays for a pre
a legal plan that uh basically i can get
a ticket
to my lawyer and they charge the legal
plan and it doesn't cost me anything
okay for matters like this yeah uh well
the the problem might be that you don't
get
uh good attention from the attorney
um and so you can try that but i would
put the attorney on a short fuse and say
you know i want this solved
uh if it's not softer than 60 days i'm
going to take it back and fix it myself
so totally understand yeah because i'm a
little bit afraid somebody slow walks
put you on the back shelf
it's a small amount it's a prepaid legal
thing i don't know what what's going on
with all that
so i want to make sure you get service
but if you want to turn it over to them
for 60 days that's fine
but do exactly what you're talking about
otherwise you're going to have to start
just really trying to source this by
pulling a copy of your credit bureau
report
and trying to get back to the original
uh
medical provider that that you owed this
to
and see if you can go back through them
to get to whoever it is
it may require just a little bit of
effort but it might
try it with a lawyer if you want but
ultimately you need to get it pushed
through
[Music]
quickly
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since
1981. we believe you should have the
freedom to focus on your health while
being supported by a community of
believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
thomas and emily are with us hey guys
how are you
nervous and excited good good to have
you well you'll be okay we never lost a
patient i know
so uh where you guys from charleston
south carolina oh
love me some charleston oh yeah talk
about a food scene almost as good as
nashville
almost maybe a little better oh dude
they recoiled at that man
it's okay they're both really good food
cities i'll tell you that
yeah yeah good welcome guys and how much
debt have you paid off
we've paid off a hundred and three
thousand eight hundred and thirty one
dollars
whoa how long did this take 28 months
okay and your range of income during
that two and a half years it was eighty
four thousand to a hundred and fifty
thousand
wow nice jump what do y'all do for a
living i work in hr for food and
beverage company
of course you do and i am a professional
chef
exactly right now i wish too i was a
student a full-time personal trainer
i did rover dog sitting during this time
and instacarted
um but now i just got my real estate
license i'm actually working for on your
elps
oh wow very cool welcome to the fold
very nice how long you guys been married
uh
three years okay excellent she looked at
you like don't mess it up
mess it up yeah and uh what kind of debt
was the 104 000
so it was mostly student loans of 74 000
and then we had seven credit cards of 16
000 and then
phone and a personal loan to wrap it up
okay who had all the student loans
it was pretty even evenly balanced i had
a little bit more than she did
okay i did a lot of d-unb yeah
all right good for you guys so uh
obviously you had talked about this
prior to marriage because right after
you get married within just a few months
of getting married
you dove in and started getting out of
debt right so tell us the story what
happened
well um we got married uh moved from
west virginia to california
most of our baby step two took place in
bakersfield california oh wow
so newlyweds new city new jobs new
church everything
and we were in a small group and a
ramsay night there
was a small business owner and i wanted
to be a full-time personal trainer so i
went to go have lunch with him like hey
you know let me ask you some questions
about
you know running a small business um he
basically looked at me like you're not
ready man
started asking me all the questions that
you had asked on the show um
and later that week at church he
was like hey i got a gift for you you
know after church we met up with him and
he gave us
the fpu box kit that had the book wow
and
the you know portion to go online and
take the fbu course so
we pretty much went home talked about it
very shortly and just started
chugging along through the lessons and
watching the videos and
emily was you know she was ready to
jump all in i was like okay i'll
certainly do this with you i don't have
a problem with this but it took me a
while
uh uncle dave to to hop to hop all on
and uh really to believe
that it was possible because we had a
pretty big hole yeah
well it's impressive well done yeah you
got to feel good y'all feel oh man it
feels amazing
yeah i mean you got rid of a hundred and
four thousand dollars worth of debt
yeah we did that's thinking amazing okay
so emily at what point in this
28 months did thomas go
all in from instead of i'll help you
with your plan
um i would think about four months in
that's not bad
it didn't take that long i i'm you know
i'm not a stubborn you didn't drag him
halfway through no no no no
yeah so what what do you think flipped
in the what was what was the flip
the switch that flipped thomas for you
where you went from
uh i'm gonna be helpful i'm not gonna be
a hindrance but i'm gonna instead i'm
gonna be half of this i'm gonna carry
the load it was really just owning up to
you know just where we were at and where
i wanted where we wanted to be
um and where i wanted to be i come from
a family
that experienced some financial
hardships growing up and i didn't want
to be
i didn't want to be in the same uh
situation i didn't want my kids
before the four months yeah you know
what happened at the fourth month
um you know i don't know what it is dave
she looked at him and said
your hair care products are coming off
the budget we're done
he said i'll take that compliment i'll
take it
um i only i'm only saying it because you
got beautiful hair and i'm jealous
you're just creeping me out at this
point it definitely was the radio show
the radio show is phenomenal after i
started listening to i guess the
debt-free screams and all the other
people who are our age
in our situation that was before you
know
it made me believe that we could do it
too so
yeah you guys are hilarious that's
hey so how has your marriage changed
you're a young married couple you went
from west virginia to california back to
the
you know the east coast how has that
changed your marriage oh it
yeah it's changed everything we've
learned so much about each other about
marriage
i would say that um why you can keep
going is for like what is the dreams
afterwards and so what do you want to be
doing where do we want to go and so your
communication of why we're doing this
was a lot stronger
right so it's a much easier way to
communicate even if it's a different
thing
or goal he wants i understand why and
how we're debt-free we can start to
prioritize how do we
go after all of them yeah yeah that's
good yeah
and now you have a road map for all
these conversations right of course
it's uh it's so nice being on the same
page especially with money
it's just we don't have to really think
about it
yeah it's just this is what it is and
this is what it's going to be so very
cool what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you've been
through financial peace university you
paid off 104 000 you're rock stars
i would say the tithe um continuing to
tie it the whole time um letting god do
with 90 what we could do with 100 100
um of the time it works and then
communication with with thomas yeah mine
would be ownership like i said earlier
it was really
you got to own up to um where you're at
especially when you start you know
thinking and talking about dreams
and where you want to be you have to
really uh go all in
um you can't you can't you
can't get out of debt easily like you
say all the time you it's it's easy to
get into debt it's hard getting out so
it was really
for me it was about ownership and
working together combining everything
realizing that it's a team effort
what was the um point in the whole
process oh man well we moved to starting
the ending uh starting with middle i
would say middle i mean we lived
in california for the majority of baby
step two and there were you know there's
so much to see and do out there
and we wanted to do as much as we could
and it was it was saying no to a lot of
things we uh we had a great
um family out there discovery church we
had some bakersfield parents dustin and
jenna who really helped us out
during those you know hard months or
hard weeks where
we were saying no to a lot of things
when people were going and doing a lot
of stuff and
uh dustin and jenna actually took us 20
year live events out there in orange
county oh wow yeah right before covid
oh wow so very cool yeah i would say we
also said yes to
things that i wouldn't have wanted to do
like 13 dogs for christmas for
dog sitting so the side hustle just
exploded yeah we uh
we don't we dogs had a lot of dogs i
walked a lot of dogs
it was quite the ordeal how how much
we sacrificed i think at one point we
had 18 dogs on the books
during a given week it was kind of wild
we would have been your favorite tenants
dave one of your rentals
we would have been like we're getting
out of debt yeah come on you had to move
to charleston to get rid of that smell
man i get that
you have no idea how many times i
steamed
carpet how many times uh you know
i was i would look at emily and be like
you're a landlord
bakersfield you just said you know what
you keep these wait wait wait
wait wait you can have it you can just
have that we're so proud of you guys
way to go it's incredible now now that
it's all done
will you ever go back in debt oh no no
no no no
no no no good very good we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that is the
next
stage in your or the next uh chapter in
your story for sure
and am i seeing a little one off to the
side our everlasting gift from
bakersfield
this is elizabeth we moved right in the
middle of a pandemic emily started a new
job um and we
we we had a little baby right in the
middle of 2020 fabulous okay
and you just got the headphones on so
you can do an actual screen
yeah this is not going to blow her blow
her mind i know
very cool well that's awesome well
you've changed your family tree and you
are leaving a legacy so the legacy
journey is our gift for you
and uh one of my my latest best seller
and then of course the total money
makeover which you can give to someone
else
pay it forward and get someone else's
journey started so proud of you guys
very very well done your heroes thank
you very well done
thomas and emily charleston south
carolina
104 000 paid off in 28 months
making 84-150 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two
[Music]
[Applause]
man she one that one from the floor yeah
and those headphones work that baby
didn't move get him flipped that's
[Applause]
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host
today amber is in dallas hey amber
what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um i am calling with a little bit of a
different question
about trying to manage life
in crisis or in high stress
so my husband and i have been married
for two and a half years
um where's the second marriage for both
of us we have five combined kids
we were 14 14 18 19 and 21.
we both work full-time um
and and you know have this family of
seven that we manage and in the in the
two and a half years we've been married
uh one full year was um cancer treatment
for me and another year
has been a pandemic and um
while we are doing really well
financially i think we are just both
completely spent and right now i feel
like we can't get our
our feet underneath us to try to
make any financial progress we're just
kind of barely holding on financially
despite making a lot of money
so i'm just trying to i guess ask
how do we manage that how do we how do
we take it into bite-sized pieces when
we really don't have the time to take
any bites so
walk me back to a couple years ago
yeah you met each other you get married
did y'all just jump in and say hey we're
going to be the brady bunch this is
going to be a blast or seven of us we're
gonna figure out as we roll
and then you got hit upside the head
with a cancer diagnosis how'd that play
out
that cancer actually came before the
marriage
it came about six weeks after the
proposal
so by then we were already sort of
jumped in
and that was an awful year that had a
job loss and a new job and
a wedding plan and a remodeling and a
move
and cancer and you know chemo surgery
had everything that year
so how you feeling now yeah
good i'm good so i i may be reading into
this but i hear in your voice
that if you talk about this just on the
wrong day
you can cry real hard and it's hard to
stop is that fair
you were just really tired you sound
exhausted not tired you sound exhausted
right
yeah so often when folks get into
survival mode
they just start sprinting as fast as
they can in a thousand different
directions
because their body says run and fight
everything
and one of the greatest gifts you can
give to yourself
is come what may we're gonna stop
and it sounds cheesy but you gotta just
acknowledge and take a state of the
union
and then you gotta sit down and grieve
what was we thought this was gonna be
what's not and only then
can you then begin to heal and make
plans for what's going to come next
but the more you rule the more you run
the more exhausted it gets so it's it's
almost as much as a
some sort of marriage retreat or family
retreat or we're just going to go away
for a day
and people do this in their businesses
we do this and we do this in our
marriage a lot now we learned this the
hard way
because i like to solve things by
getting busier and doing more stuff
which
usually led to more tough stuff
or no margin to handle that whatever
calamity came our way what do you do for
a living
i'm the controller of a university
foundation what about your host
my husband uh he works at a big um like
aeronautics
government manufacturer kind of thing
what do i do on sundays
oh well we used to go to church and and
kelvin kind of took that away we haven't
gotten back in the habit
well that wasn't a shame i was just
trying to figure out if you ever have a
down
day um you know with five kids
it's hard it's really nice all right you
just say no we're staying home
and your youngest one's 14. we do that
yeah we have 14 year old twins and then
three girls in college
oh so three are not there well
they are right now they are right now
for the summer
for sometimes the third enters college
in the fall but yeah they're they're
independent human beings though
they don't need your emotional energy or
they shouldn't
but in theory yes well i mean you can
still farm them a little bit i mean
really sunday you need to pick a day
what john's saying and get back to a
rhythm of slowing down
and i i think if you did a calendar
audit
you would probably find too much crap on
there that doesn't need to be on there
that's true that's probably true and
that is that
that is the symptom of what john was
saying
right and even the way you just
responded a lot of times folks will get
cancer they will get
they will feel that they during that
healing process everybody rallies around
them
and then there's a guilt and then
there's a i'm gonna make it up by being
everything to everybody am i right
to some degree to some degree i mean
with
we we really don't even have kids that
are highly involved in things i mean
we're not heading off to soccer games
and that sort of thing
it just between trying to keep up with a
household where things break and
and two very busy jobs and
you know it's just a lot so well
here's what um i heard from my seat is
the same thing john heard is just
exhaustion and it's almost
impossible to manage money well when
your
uh emotional tank is completely empty
right that's exactly where we are right
now and we have we have plenty of money
we make
a lot yeah we
you have no emotional energy to make it
behave
exactly that's exactly where we are yeah
i have zero control over our finances
that just comes in
the spending is as frenetic as the
earning
and as chaotic as the earning they're
both
chaotic and um there's nothing there's
it's a crazy cycle and the only way to
get off the crazy cycle is
pull the plug and rest
okay and you've been through trauma
after trauma after trauma and
trauma's cumulative think of it like a
backpack full of bricks
and until you sit down and take them out
and
show them to your husband and say this
is what i've been carrying y'all may
have experienced the same thing but you
experience him differently
grief demands to be witness so you're
gonna have to show him he's got to show
you
and you're gonna have to go whoa and
then at some point you bring your kids
into that
that the old vessel bender vander kulk
book the classic
the body keeps the score it's got a tab
on you right so until you guys stop
and go we have been through hell
we i mean i went through covid as well
in the sense of i it was a year from
hell trying to keep this business open
and running and keep
you know uh an extra dose of the haters
coming around and all that kind of stuff
you know we had all of that here but you
know what i didn't have cancer the year
before
so i came into that strong
emotionally spiritually physically
strong
now i got drained through that year but
you came into that year
with chemo off the back side of chemo
absolutely so you you know you like the
wwf you tagged up between two traumas
right right and then last year got a
promotion which is a great thing but it
has meant
just a full out at work
well and he's gonna have to dial that
down yeah and you're gonna have to dial
it down you guys are gonna have to have
some margin where you just sit
and breathe and and you won't have to do
that very long before your budget will
start to make sense
because you don't have the power right
now emotionally to tell yourself no
right or you're 14 year olds now it
takes a lot of power until 14 years
that's completely draining but eating
out when you're exhausted is
that you know that's the other thing
yeah you you know you're
you and you don't eat well right because
you're eating
chunk and then then you don't feel good
it which so the cycle perpetuates yeah
you ask your 14 year olds hey you guys
pick up your clothes and they go i don't
want to and you don't have any energy to
push back on a 14 year old
to say whatever and then they get a
little sassier and
the whole thing comes back to this one
magic word of intentionality
yeah so i'm going to tell you to audit
your calendar and look at your bosses
and back it down
so that you've got a little margin to
love each other well and put that
staying down on a budget and then you've
got the emotional
strength to make your money and the
people touching it
behave okay all right that's helpful
that does not come from where you i i
hear you i feel sorry for because i've
been right where you are
and when you are down to nothing when
you're down to the emotional nub
i mean it's just hard the gas you just
got to get some gas back in your tank
and
hey and and let me just tell you the
fact that you're there after what you've
been through
does not make you a bad person it makes
you a human and you're strong
normal humans normal humans would be
right where you are
that's right you're not crazy you're not
crazy you're strong
you've got to do anything wrong but and
the beautiful thing is you're smart
enough to have recognized where you are
that's right and so i think you can turn
this and you'll be surprised how fast
you turn it actually
but it's gonna it's a new word it's the
ancient word you have to use it
no no we can't do that no we're not
spending that
no no we're turning off the tv no
put the screens down no we're gonna
breathe on the back porch
this is the ramsey show have a friend or
family member that needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author
of the book redefining anxiety is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
your money your mental health anything
you want to talk about we're here
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five
two two five betsy starts off this hour
in baltimore maryland hi
betsy how are you hi dave i'm fine
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
how can we help
um a few years ago i
got divorced after 21 years and
three years ago i bought a house
and uh i'll just say that i really
didn't have all my wits about me
and i bought a house from a flipper and
i
didn't have i thought i had a realtor
that i could trust
and it turned out that i didn't so i
have this
92 year old house that needs
a fair amount of work i was also
talked into getting
a seven year arm mortgage
and i'm in the third year
what do you owe on the house i owe 100
i guess i owe about 180 okay i think
that's about where it is now if you were
to put it on the market without doing
any work to it like it sits today
what could you get for it well i paid
275. if you were to put it on the market
today
like it sits with the work that it needs
on it what could you get for it
well that's my issue because my
conscience says that what is the house
worth
i i would say it would probably go in
the market for 275 i just don't know
why you think it'll bring that
i think it could yes good get within a
real estate elp
at ramseysolutions.com get it on the
market and sell it
that was my question i didn't know
whether i should
get out of this yes and get out of it
yes okay everything you described in
this entire conversation
was the opposite of fun
right well yeah the house became more
than i
thought the deal was bad going in and
the deal has been bad since you sat
there and you've got a bad mortgage
right there's nothing here that just
happiness
no on top of that it is a reminder of
the
mindset you were in of a poor state you
were in
when your life fell apart it's just a
reminder every day
it is it is get out of it yeah the
broken house kind of feels like the
broken you that
went in and bought the broken house
every time you drive up in front of it
do i do i sell it as is yes ma'am yes
ma'am you're not in the business of
rehabbing there's somebody that would
have already seen too much hgtv that's
going to run right into this thing
yeah there's a chip and joanna out there
somewhere
smiling big and hey will you do me a
huge favor
yes the next time you buy a house the
next time you rent a house
i want you to change your language and
this is important because it's going to
make you
walk a little bit taller i want you to
change your language from
i got talked into and to
i did it it was dumb i did it i went in
a good state
i did this and now i'm going to make it
right i'm going to sell it i'm going to
sell it as is i'm gonna make a hundred
thousand dollars so i'm gonna put down
another property
that i've got my wits about me i'm gonna
make good decisions get good counsel
and i'm gonna stand six inches taller
starting today so you're going to
understand
the deal you're going to understand what
the property is worth you're going to
understand what you're getting into
uh so that no matter how competent or
incompetent who you're dealing with is
that you're not going to be taken they
got to go through betsy from maryland
right right right
i just was concerned about if i move out
of here
and the houses are so expensive
listen even if you go rent for a while
and you you know you it takes you a
while to find a reasonable deal
the market has to calm down before you
find a reasonable deal
nothing about the deal that you're in is
fun and so this is a really good time to
get out of an
unfun deal sell it okay
okay and is summertime okay or should i
have better betty betty
salad yeah becky how long have you been
divorced
uh four years four and a half years was
that a surprise did it shock
you it wasn't a shock but
was it devastating the whole thing was a
lie the whole thing was alive so it was
devastating okay here's what has not
happened in four years you've not
learned to trust betsy again
that's true and the marriage fell apart
but at the end of the day you blame
betsy betsy should have known
and at this point you've got to stand
back up and say betsy is worth
being trusted is worth good councils
worth good friends is worth
not having to ask 17 different questions
when one of the smartest guys in america
is telling you what to do
john i was talking about myself not you
clearly
clearly clearly clearly i mean yeah
the the trick is trust me betsy there's
gonna be a lot of peace that comes if
you just go keep your life real simple
and rent a nice place for a little while
and you got a little pile of money in
the bank and you don't have any issues
anymore
and all of the emotions and the problems
that this house represents and the
regrets that this house represents are
in the rearview mirror
and the windshield is bigger than the
rear view mirror we call that grace
look forward look forward and give betsy
grace
yeah yeah you're okay you're you're
smarter than you're giving yourself
credit for you're stronger than you're
giving yourself credit for
good stuff open phones triple eight
eight two
five five two two five you know we
always say personal finance is 80
behavior it's 20 head knowledge
um and i i have always
anecdotally seen the correlation between
bad decisions
being paralyzed on making a decision uh
to the things that have happened in
somebody's life i mean um
we had a caller in another hour that had
gone through chemo
followed by pandemic they these are not
financial things
but they always affect financial things
right
and financial things always affect them
that's exactly right and so this idea
that somehow money is its own little
category
siloed over here to the side from your
emotions your relationships your
betrayals your hurts
your physical well-being
your the time you were molested when you
were 7 49 years ago
all of these things play into your money
that's right and they play into like you
said your marriages and your work
relationships it plays into all that
stuff
and we dave we have um we've got a
society a culture that says you
are the worst thing you've ever done
you are the worst thing that's ever
happened to you and we do not have a
collective sense either individually or
as a
culture of what redemption looks like
what's saying
i made a stupid decision and i'm better
than that i'm not going to do it again
and what going forward looks like and we
see folks like betsy who are good people
who are trapped in that
that cyclone of doubt and shame from the
past
from the past and the hardest person
to get over doubting is yourself yeah
good stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five well you know what can
really suck and that's called living
paycheck to paycheck at the end of the
month you have too much month left at
the end of the money
you can never get ahead you feel like a
rat in a wheel
but you don't have to live like this
stop
running in the wheel stop and we can
show you how to start making progress
you need to check out financial peace
university you can find
it at ramsey plus this membership will
show you how to make changes that you
need
to get the results you want you want to
get out of debt you want to be on a plan
you want to get control you want to get
traction
financial peace university can show you
how to do that and again it's located at
ramsey plus
it gives you complete access to that
plus all kinds of other courses
plus the every dollar budgeting app yeah
it's all there
and listen if you want to start making
real progress you can do a free trial of
ramsey plus that gives you access to
financial peace university and all these
other things
text the word trial to 33 789
text trial two three three
seven eight nine
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you know i was talking with
some of our marketing team this morning
at ramsey plus and um
i was trying to remember see if you
remember this
when you signed up for netflix
do you remember way back in the day yeah
i mean well number one i had it back
when they used to send the statement
they mailed them to you they mailed them
to you in these little weird little
fiberglass sleeve things and then i quit
that because i kept getting
there was i couldn't watch them fast
enough i felt like i was
it didn't work okay but and then of
course now it's on online through your
apple tv or whatever and you you can
it's nine bucks or whatever 10 bucks or
12 bucks wherever they charge now and
it's
um but i didn't sign up
for netflix i signed up to watch a show
that somebody told me about huh that
happened to be on
netflix netflix that's right and that
was the gateway drug
and then we got off of it and ten years
later i remembered that
netflix or five years later has lots of
movies
but that initial one it as i wanted to
watch those movies right yeah
yeah so yeah i mean nobody went to
blockbuster because they liked it
they went there because that's where the
movie was right and it wasn't always
there
right it was the other thing uh and then
you forget to take it back
and then they would come and mortgage
your house take your car from you yeah
you know this kind of stuff that was a
that was not a model that
anyone hated to see go bye-bye
but uh but now we've got access in our
living room you just punch it up and it
comes up right you don't have to
you don't have to go to the store and
get a vhs tape some of you people don't
know what that is look it up you'll
probably see it on google
um but yeah it's an interesting thing i
i just i
i don't remember signing up for netflix
i remember signing up to watch
the show or i did that the other day
with i didn't sign up to get
apple tv everyone kept telling me about
this show ted lasso yeah
and so i signed up to watch ted last
night so
it happened to be on apple tv tv yeah
that's exactly how this works yeah
that's a different way of doing and
lasso is great by the way have you
binged it all the way through
i can't tell you the number of people
said i think they i think somebody made
a movie about you where you were
oh that was incredible i loved
everything you're not as nerdy as he is
but that that that that that show is so
satirical it's so well written
oh it's beautifully it's a great it's so
funny yeah
and uh but and and it'll catch you off
guard and
all of a sudden your eyes will be
leaking too yeah and you get sympathetic
for characters you shouldn't be and it's
just
it's very interesting it humanizes
everybody which i think is a more honest
way to do art these days but yeah
it's very very well done yeah that's
that's exactly what happened there
yeah because i couldn't tell you where's
you know yellowstone
we watched that thing right it's great
yeah i don't know right this second i
don't know where it sits
it's on one of the things right it's on
one of those places but i didn't sign up
for the thing i signed up to go watch
that
you know and so that's an interesting
way we do things in our culture now
they're very interesting so that's kind
of the way ramsey plus is i guess
it's like it's not it's like netflix you
don't certainly sign up for mbps you go
to financial base university which
happens
to be on on it or i want to go i keep
hearing about anthony o'neil's show i'm
going to go check it out
yeah it's he's got some stuff on nc plus
check that out it's on ramsey plus or or
you know i want to watch the ramsey
network it's on youtube that's right but
you don't like
sign up for youtube and then randomly
find anthony you might yeah but
um because he's a big deal on youtube
but uh but but
you know but more than likely you're
going to find him
oh and it's on youtube yeah that's it
that's so interesting to me
but the hope is that your the products
you put out are so good
that now you buy it because it's apple
yeah if apple says you need a watch
that's uh
okay right eventually yeah but but are
the shows are so good did you go see
what other stuff
the quality is right that's what other
shows they put just quality right you
know the hbo documentary series they've
had they've had a good reputation
most of them being pretty good yeah and
so when hbo has a dock come out people
want to see you know it's gonna be good
they've done a they built a pretty good
brand around that
as an example that's just a consumer's
observation i am not endorsing any of
this
so um it's just a very interesting kind
of a user experience with the way
our minds work when we're doing these
things very interesting
brittany's with us in santa barbara hi
brittany how are you
hi there i'm greg how are you better
than i deserve what's up
okay so my husband and i are going to be
moving our family to eastern tennessee
in probably one to two years um we have
two rentals here both with mortgages
and our primary with a mortgage so our
dilemma
is should we sell the rentals right now
pay off our last small debt and then do
1031
in tennessee to buy two rentals in cash
or
should we just pay the capital gains
here um pay off our last small debt
and purchase rentals and those primary
when we move
cash you call dave ramsey
yes yeah cash so you solomon
but if you sell them now you got to buy
now you can't do a 1031 two years from
now after you sell
right right right we have family in
tennessee that could look after the
properties
um why do you have to sell there why are
you waiting two years
well my husband's finishing up school oh
and so
we'd like to have him finish here in
california and then
yeah that's our main reason sure that
makes sense okay yeah finish up and then
put all the properties on the market
and come over here and you should be
able to come to tennessee pay cash for
everything
that's what we thought yeah we've been
you know watching the um
property values a lot well they're going
to move they're going to move between
now and then and i don't know
you know i don't know how much they're
going to move up or down whether
california is going to get in trouble by
then
that's our fear exactly it's possible
it could happen i mean if you say if you
start seeing um
cracks in the market i haven't seen any
cracks in the market yet the only cracks
i've seen are the leading indicator of
how many people leaving the state
yeah but that's the only thing that's
bothering me in terms of eventually that
that's going to catch up with the
economy there and uh catch up with the
supply demand curve on the real estate
but
uh because there's a bazillion more
people leaving than coming in
to california and new york right now so
that eventually is going to affect the
economy but i don't know
when and if i'm you i'm not panicked
about that i'm just going to start
watching but if i start seeing the real
estate market
locally right around you right there in
santa barbara which is a wonderful area
beautiful area if i start seeing the
market slow down
and get to be a little bit uh lethargic
i'm going to start talking about going
ahead and liquidating these things
but i don't think you need to today
because i think you've still got a hot
market like a lot of the other areas
yeah yeah it's definitely up yeah if you
could put if you put a house on the
market right now it'll sell fast won't
it
yes yeah so you're not you're not
exactly in a
thing here you're not exactly in a
problem so you know that that's the deal
so
i'm just going to sit on them for today
when you get ready to move
if the market has not made you go ahead
and put them on the market earlier
then you move them and do your 1031s and
come to tennessee and pay cash when you
make the move
very interesting and the 1031 is just
the exchange on the
trains it's a trade you're trading one
house for another
in the old days we used to have to buy
we have to use stuff to get the uh
like if we wanted to buy a house in east
tennessee
you would have to get uh that owner to
trade with you
okay but now you can sell the house into
an escrow account a special
1031 escrow account use those funds to
buy another property
and the irs treats it as if you traded
for that property so you have to pay
that there's no capital gains
capital your basis rolls in your gains
roll into the next deal gotcha
you roll them in and eventually you'll
get tagged on that if you ever sell out
while you're live
but it keeps you from having to pay
right now
a 1031 tax deferred exchange like kind
properties it's investment property to
investment property
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free
stage peter and catherine are with us
hey guys how are you
good afternoon welcome welcome where do
you guys live we're in columbus ohio
oh nice drive to nashville
uh how much debt have you paid off 177
000 in 29 months
and your range of income during that
time 130 to 170.
good what do you guys do for a living i
work in human resources for
a large specialty retailer i am a
salesman for cutco closing gifts and
kitchen knives oh good for you
very fun good for you guys so what kind
of debt was the 177
000 it was a lot of uh student loans
and back irs debt
credit cards family loans
just about everything everything but car
loans really you were fairly normal
and normal socks yeah that's not fun so
how much did you owe the kgb i mean the
irs
i think it was around 15 16 000 over a
period of a couple years
self-employment yeah what'd you say
self-employment
self-employment without paying the taxes
yeah that'll get you
that was an awesome point that will bite
you
uh bite you right there so all right
very cool so what happened
29 months ago that lit this fuse well it
starts a little earlier than that
we met each other end of uh end of april
in 2018
we got to know each other pretty well
and
catherine realized i was in a pretty
poor financial
state and it made her pretty nervous
so most of this was yours yeah my bad
decisions
okay and well we know the irs was that
was already set up okay
yes it was and she told me you know i i
think
if we're going to have a future
relationship with each other i am
nervous about
your finances and your debt that was so
sweet
i'm i'm i'm speechless that's awesome
instead of like going dude if you don't
fix this you're out
she said somebody told you that's a
phrase that's a great phrase somebody
told you
that your values were important
and that hitching yourself to a giant
lead cement block that was going to get
thrown into a river wasn't a great idea
yeah who taught you that
i mean we both grew up in great
financial households
okay um so we had really good role
models your boundaries and your but the
delivery on that too
it wasn't like fix issue jerk it was
like it was so sweet it was implied
it was so sweet i know it was it was
something she's an agent
of delivery she gives bad news with
smiles and gentlemen that's right it's
great delivery i just liked it
so now you're motivated because you got
the message well my
mail the response was i i i know what
i'm doing i can i've got a way of doing
this
i understand there's dave ramsey and all
those yeah
i know how to do it her response was
well you might know how to do it but the
way you're doing it is
terrible oh you married an hr director
brother
and she actually does have a sense of
humor believe it or not that's awesome i
believe
this is great so fast forward we ended
up taking financial peace university ed
and joy nickerson were great
coordinators and during that time it
really helped us to get on the same page
financially and during that time we got
engaged
so we knew that we were going to be
starting our marriage on the same
footing
because obviously finance is one of the
biggest stumbling blocks with
marriages yeah and we would just like to
start off on a better footing
than stumbling good for you guys and
after about six months of
yeah ish dave ish uh we decided let's
really hunker down let's get the budget
down another six months of
doing that we thought you know we're
kind of getting the hang of this and we
decided
we would like to pass on this
information in this
way of life frankly uh to others and so
we signed up to be coordinators
oh thank you wow that's all in our
pleasure and our first class was
was one person so we got a lot of
one-on-one time and it helped us to
really
figure out where going to figure out
what we were doing also stay
um stay bought in yeah and remind why
we're doing what we're doing
and we got to run another class we had
four folks in there two young couples
that had just been married and in a
similar position to where we were
and it was just a great they'll be
waiting
to be friends for life yeah wow look at
you guys
it's so powerful well done well done
and don't you love the way she looked
and she said yeah you may know what
you're doing but it doesn't look like
you're not doing it yeah so so
you you have a brilliant tactful woman
that you married
what was it that fondly convinced you to
look in the mirror and go you're exactly
right
um there's a humbling moment there it it
is it uh
it's kind of biting when somebody
criticizes
your the way you do as a great salesman
you always have a comeback that's what
you're great at but at some point you
had to stop
and look in the mirror and go you're
right i'm you're right you know looking
trying to pay off one credit card so
that i have money to
buy groceries so that i have some more
money to pay off another credit card and
juggling those back and forth and
realizing
this is no way to live my parents didn't
live this way uh
i don't want to live this way and she's
willing to
work with me yeah he wasn't an immediate
deal killer so i thought this is a good
woman
amen this is a beautiful story
both of you are all both good too man
yeah you're awesome this is very
cool i mean you've you've engaged in
some of the hardest things that human
beings can engage in
uh the idea of getting engaged getting
married oh and by the way while we're
doing all that we pay off 177 thousand
dollars
that's pretty stinking incredible giving
feedback and receiving feedback
are two hearts too yeah that's
incredible we uh we both owned homes
when we got married
so um we had to decide who got to keep
the house
i'm guessing you won i did
so there's a theme here just saying uh i
did win
but uh so we had a lot of long
conversations after we'd taken financial
peace like we had gotten married we both
had homes
we moved in together once we got married
and um obviously we're not living in
different homes but we
uh we talked for a while about what do
we do with the other house
should we keep it should we rent it out
and like
it's it's got a mortgage on it it's not
like we owned it outright so it was
like nope we're over leveraged we need
to sell it
and put that money towards and that
helped accelerate this thing yes it did
yeah we had some returns from the house
but and all my stuff that we had to sell
so that it all fits yeah that's right it
is consolidating to one house
well welcome to marriage this is awesome
guys
this is so cool so what do you tell
people you've led financial peace you've
paid off 177
000 um someone says how did you do that
what are the keys to getting out of debt
because you're professionals you've
actually done it
yeah i mean for me it's a right
relationship with money and a right
relationship with god
so understanding that it's not our money
um
i think was huge for both what is that
what does that cause you to do
differently
uh i i think it it really changes our
point of view towards generosity like
this is
not our money anyway so we can have like
as you've said many times the most fun
you can have with money which is giving
it away
and i think i struggled with that during
the journey i was like oh we can't
you know we can't give money to people i
don't know we just
that was something i think that came up
but i think that right relationship
continuing to tithe and be submissive
with
uh the blessings that god has given us i
think has been
critical yeah i would say for me it was
sticking with
the budget was the biggest thing because
once you've made those hard decisions
ahead of time
you don't really have to make the other
decisions there's no strain once you the
strain is getting it on the paper
but then and committing to doing it but
if you're going to do what's on the
paper once it's on there it's just
execution
yeah yeah that's that's a good point i
like that and it was sometimes
challenging when we got a big uh
you know a sales bonus or great sales
month or she got a bonus like oh we
could go buy stuff
but it became the more we did it the
more we got into the habit of
living below our means and it became
more fun to see
how many debts and accounts we could
close out than how much stuff we could
buy
it gets gamified we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in the story you're going to be
continuing to leave a legacy
and an extra copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and help
somebody with their
start their journey start the begin
process thank you for leading the class
you guys are amazing
peter and catherine columbus ohio 177
000 paid off in 20 months 29 months
making 130 to 170.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
touchdown baby that's how it's done
right there this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five john is with us
in uh pennsylvania hi john how are you
i'm doing well dave thanks for taking my
call i appreciate it sure what's up
um so i think i'm in baby step three but
i'm not
sure um i paid paid off all our debt and
paid off
recently finished paying off the car
we're debt-free except uh
my oldest son um i've co-signed some of
his college loans
so i'm not sure uh
should i put them into my debt snowball
and start paying them off
or just you know step in if if he starts
having trouble paying him
is he paying them uh well he just
graduated in may
oh and he's still looking for a job okay
so he got six months four he has to
start paying
yeah what's how much is the owed on
these loans
uh well all together it's right about
thirty thousand
how much debt have you paid off so far
um well really haven't paid off anything
there
there's a couple different loans oh i
thought you were on
and you say you paid off some debt my
debt
yes i'm sorry um uh
gosh uh probably close to
96 thousand wow
yeah 96 000. what do you make household
income uh
household income is about 79. okay
well you've done very very well yeah
well i mean
this is what this is what accountants
call a contingent
liability meaning that you are liable if
he doesn't pay that's what cosigning
sets you up for
so uh you you are technically debt-free
you're technically on baby step three
okay uh i would want your baby step
three to be pretty beefy
your emergency fund so don't do three to
six go like
six to eight or so yeah yeah i'm gonna
probably cheat a little bit
up in the eight side just to kind of
offset the fact that you have a kid that
has not gotten a job
and he's got thirty thousand dollars
he's supposed to start paying on and if
he doesn't you're about to
and if you have to if you have to start
paying the payments because he doesn't
then i'm just gonna treat it like my dad
i'm gonna stop everything and knock it
out
yeah he's got a computer science degree
uh
and he did very well in school so we're
pretty confident he's gonna get a decent
paying job
me too but i'm just you know at the
moment
for today i would just set aside extra
but
at the six month mark if he doesn't
start paying this on time and they start
bothering you
just roll up your sleeves and knock it
out okay and john take him
if you haven't already take him to lunch
because he is going to get a good job
and make sure he knows to not go buy a
car in a fancy apartment put him into
financial peace university knock this
thing
yeah well so we found out about you
about two years ago
um before you know uh he went off to the
college he went to
um and and so it's a little bit of a
moral issue for me because my my
youngest son
um he's sort of getting a free ride uh
because i work at a college
yeah and so he we're getting like a
tremendous discount
uh for him um why didn't everyone go
there and they didn't have the degree he
wanted
at my school so okay well i mean don't
know
i don't see it as a moral issue listen
fair is something that happens at the
county
yeah that's a great line dave
good one you know so i mean it's just it
is what it is
if you've got a child that has uh that
is a you know a different situation then
it's a different situation and so
equal is not fair fair is not equal and
that's
that's uh that's just part of the way
life works out and um uh
i i you know my kids did not get the
exact
same amount uh the younger one ended up
with possibly more
because we had a better start by the
time he came along
and uh but they've it's all worked out
for all of them they're going to be just
fine
so and you can do something that blesses
one of the other ones a little bit later
if you want to or something like that
the one that you didn't cost you
anything you know that kind of thing but
anyway yeah you can help if you want to
help but i would be prepared to pay it
off immediately
as fast as you can if he fails
in paying it that's the way i would
position it thank you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five aubry is in salt lake city hey
aubrey what's up
hi thank you for taking my call sure um
i have a question so my husband and i
got married three years ago and he
is graduating at the end of the year
with his phd in mechanical
engineering wow what's he going to do
teach
um he wants to eventually he's got an
emphasis in aerospace he's been working
on
research with new aircraft very cool
that's fun um but our question is he has
been
he's known about you since he started
school so he has no debt
for his school and our question our
debate at home
is we really want to pay cash for a
house
but i personally don't see that as
possible without saving for
five plus years depending on his income
and so we were just kind of wondering
when is it
where he's 33 and i'm i'm 30. we're
wondering when is it
time to do the 15 even though we want to
pay 100
for a house generally we tell folks
three years
that you don't want to lay off of your
retirement longer than that
but if you have a goal of paying for a
house and you're a phd
in mechanical engineering and you're in
the aerospace world
uh i'm i'm projecting a pretty dead gum
good income here
and so if you're 33 and you have a paid
for house
you're probably still going to be
multi-gazillionaires by the time you get
to retirement if you just invest from
that point forward
so if it takes you five years it doesn't
kill me in this situation
you see why
hello yeah um
i just ran a bunch of numbers and i'm a
little bit i don't know we have two kids
and i just
maybe it's just worried if you can pay
cash for a house by what age
by well five years would be 38. okay at
38 years old
and 30 years of 68 of making 200 000
plus a year and investing substantial
amounts because you have absolutely no
house payment
if you just invest a house payment for
30 years
that's 10 million dollars i don't know
where you've been running your numbers
but
what would have been a house payment
that you don't have to be more
conservative
it just depends on what he wants to do
he doesn't want to work at the big
places well if he's not going to go earn
an income commensurate with what i'm
talking about that may change the
formula he's going to make 30 000
a year because he's taking some
half-butt government job or something
when he ought to be making
10x that then no that's a i do change my
answer then
so yeah you guess you need to talk that
through with him but i'm projecting a
big income in this household
and with no house payment for all those
years you'll have no trouble
landing this thing yeah
but i mean if you want to go i i
i mean i would think even as a professor
teaching yeah
he'd be making 160 years yeah
depending on how good he is and i i also
don't see a challenge with taking out a
10-year mortgage then
and yeah working it backwards working
backwards if you want to start saving 15
and take out a short mortgage that's
fine but i love the idea of paying cash
for the house and being free your entire
life
but you have to commit to all sides of
the equation which is the income side
uh the investment side after the house
is purchased
uh and the paying cash side and we're
going to be on an intentional detail
budget
to where we hit all of these goals well
then it's going to be a weighing so if
we want to say for five years or four
years
i'm gonna take job x yeah and as a
family we're gonna hit the gas
show that for the back 30 years then
take that job man take that job plus
another job take that job and adjunct
somewhere else and be a professor there
and
do what you got to do so you're going to
pay cash for house and you're
man you're done yeah you're being great
i mean if you have a paid for house when
you're 38 and you're making six figures
you've won
you you if you invest reasonably out of
that you're gonna have
10 million dollars i mean you really
will so you should be fine
but um you know if you're investing
in good growth stock mutual funds at
stock market rates of return you'll be
there
you're going to be just fine but if you
don't play through on all of that then
yeah you just end up with a paid for
house and a bad job right and that's
that's certainly not what we're
recommending definitely not
[Music]
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books james childs is our
producer kelly daniel is our associate
producer and phone screener
john dr john deloney is my co-host today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality
best-selling author host to the dr john
deloney show
a very exploding popular podcast
there you go check it out you don't want
to miss it he talks about mental health
there and boundaries and relationships
and anxiety and
how to get along with others and things
that people don't know how to do in our
culture anymore
so we'll talk here with you about that
and about your money in your life the
phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five brendan is
with us in kansas city
hi brendan how are you i'm good thank
you for asking
um yeah i've been a big fan of the show
successfully working the baby steps but
unfortunately that's not
really why i'm calling today more of a
john situation okay
i'll try and be brief um so my sister
was
going through her divorce um so we let
her and her
son move in with us that went pretty
badly
she's dealing with some substance abuse
issues and uh
so we kind of confronted on that a few
times and eventually we kind of
gave her the choice either go into rehab
and get help or
find somewhere else to live um so she
went into rehab came back it was good
for a month or so
relapsed and that's when we told her she
had to had to go
um so her son's living with us
she's was homeless for about a week and
now she's living in
we flip houses on the side she's living
in a house that was flipping
um so that's kind of where i'm at she
kicked her out of one house into the
other one
essentially yeah i just felt terrible
because she had nowhere to go
and me and my wife decided we could let
her live in that house until we were
done working on it and sold it but
um that's not working either yeah she
doesn't seem to be doing any
what's she abusing what kind of
substance alcoholism
okay why did um what happened with rehab
uh she went through a 30 day like
inpatient program
she got back she didn't listen to any of
their advice you know
she was supposed to go to aaa meetings
and stuff for uh you know follow up with
things and she
didn't really she did all right on her
own for a few weeks and
and just started drinking again and
hiding it and so
yeah is she okay with her son staying
with you guys
uh yeah yeah and we are too that's yeah
that's uh
how old is he he's third he's 13 years
old
that's hard surprisingly a great kid
actually
with everything he's been through but no
he's got an uncle that loves him he's
got a mom that loves him right
yeah yeah yeah yeah she's struggling she
doesn't know how to do it well but she
does love him
so how can we help man um i just
i don't is it i just feel like guilty
like i should
be helping her more doing more for her
um but at the same time like
like she's not helping herself so why
should i
be you know i don't know i feel like
it's enabling to continue to be there
for her um i'm just struggling with
have i helped enough or should i do more
or
yeah i ultimately you making sure her
her son's got a roof over his head and a
family that loves him and some sort of
structure and boundaries
is a generational um
shifting gift okay and you have
given her opportunity and another
opportunity another opportunity
i think it's going to be what you and
your wife defined by help but at the end
of the day
she's going to have to come to the
conclusion that she's going to have to
get help be a part of some programs
change her life and ultimately decide
every day for the rest of her life that
she's going to remain
sober and you can't do that you can't
make that happen for her that's a
decision that she's going to have to
come to on her own
unfortunately most of the time people
have to find themselves with no other
place to go
right and that's hard and it's
heartbreaking
um but at the end of the day you're
gonna end up drowning yourself and your
family trying to solve somebody else's
problem that you can't solve
yeah and that's like you know i feel
still guilt about that like i should
should do more for her yeah um
let me help you you you've may have
already done too much
yeah okay so here's what john said he
said define help
so this is just regular guy talk because
i don't have the
letters after my name he does but um
enablers all of us are enablers
sometimes
and an enabler is someone who is a very
nice
sweet person like you compassionate
and all of us have some of that even me
and uh uh you know i have the ability to
go there
but what happens is where you cross the
line it from helping
or from loving someone well to uh
being an enabler meaning you're giving a
drunk a drink is the classic line right
where you cross that line is where you
defined help wrong and
when you cross that line when you say
i'm defining help as
i'm now participating in the crazy
assisting in the crazy
rather than pushing against the crazy
and so when you allow when you create a
situation where she can continue
in this you're participating in the
crazy that's helping
that's defining help wrong does that
make sense
yeah yeah and so one of the i think one
of the um
a negative default can be to cut off all
talk until you fix it you can't talk to
us you can't see anybody
and what i'll often say is addiction is
a communication issue
i mean sorry it's a connection issue
right it's a lack of connection people
go try to solve that connection through
addiction
so here's a great a great example i'm
gonna make sure your son
always has a roof over his head we're
gonna give him structure i'm gonna take
care of him
i'm gonna be at cracker barrel every
saturday morning at nine o'clock and i'm
gonna pay for your breakfast and i'd
love to see you
but july 1 rent stops from us
you're gonna have to go get a job and
decide you want to get well
and what you're doing there is i'm and
she's gonna say you don't love me you
don't care about me no i do
i love you a lot i love you so much i'm
not going to create a situation where
you can stay drunk all the time
but i'm not i'm not going to i'm not
going to threaten my relationship with
you
i'm going to keep showing up at
crackerbread i'm going to keep taking
care of your kid
and um i'm going to cover the cost of
breakfast every time because i love you
and you're my sister and you're gonna
tell me some crazy stories and they're
gonna make me laugh
anytime you call me i'll feed you that's
right but we're not going to
pay for you to be in a situation that
allows you to continue to be a drunk
that's right because that's not helping
you and i love you too much
to participate in your crazy yeah and
the moment you get out of rehab and you
say i'm ready
i'm going to my aaa meetings i do my 30
days in a row
i'll be cheering with you oh my gosh
i'll be there clapping when you get your
coin that's right
uh i'll be telling you how great you are
i'm gonna tell your son how much you
love him every day and i'm not gonna
shame you when you mess up
i'm not gonna do any of that i'm gonna
be here for you i love you
but i'm not going to support you while
you
run the habit there you go i'll be your
biggest cheerleader but not your biggest
benefactor
that's your you know that's tough love
no that's
just love yeah just love and hey
unfortunately for you there is no easy
way through this yeah it's a pain though
it's gonna be heartbreaking
it's a pain in the butt because you have
to watch people that you can't control
harm themselves not only you can't
control them but you love them
yeah yeah and you you know it's people
you love doing stupid stuff
heartbreaking they're everywhere good
for you for taking care of that little
boy
very hard yeah you're a good man yeah
you got a good heart
oh so hard so hard it's crazy in every
family
if you think there's not near family
it's you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
well the housing market is hot that
would be an understatement your house
could be worth a lot more today than it
was
20 minutes ago that is not an
understatement that's
the truth your old insurance policy
might not give you enough coverage
so if your house is worth 50 000 more
than it was
a year ago and your insurance policy has
the old value stated on it that's all
you will get if it burns
hello you need to update your policy and
guess what your insurance agent didn't
call you either
some policies automatically raise your
coverage a little depending on home
price but are depending on inflation
rates but
not enough to cover what's going on
right now and if your agent hasn't
followed up and reset
your policy you do not have adequate
coverage
so we recommend endorsed local providers
for car
and homeowners insurance and you can get
a much better deal
and you'll get an agent that stays on
top of things these are independent
agencies
agents they compare multiple policies to
find the best possible coverage for your
home
and your budget text home to 33
789 and talk to a trusted insurance pro
about finding the right coverage for you
getting the proper amount at the best
possible deal text
home 233 seven
eight nine richard is with us in atlanta
hi
richard welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys how you guys doing today better
than we deserve
sir how can we help hi i'm so i'm in
baby subs four and six
i make about 30 36 000 after tax a year
um i had an idea of working the next
year getting a
side job and living off the side job
money so working about 20 hours extra a
week
at a different job and pocketing
my primary jobs money and i was thinking
about putting it towards
saving it towards retirement so i'll
just try and get your opinion on it
um i have six months saved up right now
so i'm just trying to
get you get you guys opinion on it
you're single
i am single uh i i have two roommates
who pay my mortgage right now
um yep feel me that is my home how old
are you
24. yeah i'm all in man
it doesn't hurt anything yeah um is it
necessary for you to have a good life
no uh if you start saving
prospering the next year i could take a
year off and work my butt off
doesn't hurt i mean you know i want to
work hard
make more money and have more money
should i do that well the answer unless
you're
you know giving up something major in
your life by doing that is yes
uh that's where money comes from so yeah
there's nothing wrong with that
but i also don't want you to think that
that you know you're 24 you make 36 000
a year you need to panic about
retirement
you can start saving 15 of your income
now and do that every year as you get
raises as your career grows
and you will be just fine
would it make more sense to put that
toward retirement and let it grow or
put the 36 000 towards my mortgage
well we teach that you should be putting
15 of your income towards retirement and
everything else towards your mortgage
so both
56 000 because of working extra
then 15 of 56 000 would go into
retirement that year
and any other money you can scrape out
of your budget that you want to do
something important
with would go towards paying off your
mortgage early
that's what we teach baby steps four
five and six
we also teach especially for 24 year old
go getters don't over complicate it
don't try to outsmart the system just
follow it
yeah and you know it does kind of feel
like that you're trying to figure a way
to game the system here
and and my point is you can relax a
little i think you're doing okay
and it's okay to work extra make some
extra money and then just follow
the process and you're gonna get there
you're gonna get there just fine
but it's not like if you know if i front
load this thing can i never work again
it's like yeah well probably but
that's not what i find as normative
among baby step millionaires everyday
millionaires
that i meet everywhere tracy's in
birmingham hi tracy welcome to the
ramsey show
hi um my question
is i am married to a self-made
millionaire
we've been married for three years
together for a total of
seven um i
put my career on hold and i kind of help
him with
everything his businesses multiple
businesses
um and everything i
well the one job that i have that
actually get a paid salary from
is i am a project slash office manager
for an electrical contracting company
um and we do jobs across the nation so
that is the one job that i do to
actually get a salary
um for but on top of that i help them
with
everything of his other businesses that
he has
and all his personal things like you
know like a normal couple would
but um
when we got married i signed a prenup
because i know you know i understand
that you
um everything before me is yours and
your
success is yours um
but i'm starting to feel like we're
never going to build
together and i've put my career on hold
and i'm helping out with him and his
things
tracy what else is going on um
there's actually a lot
i've been wanting to have kids
and that's something that i feel like
he's bringing me along with as well
and i feel like everything in our lives
is
his like there's nothing that's ours
like
i don't feel like he values my opinion
or
you know why you feel this way because
that's the truth it's true
that's why you feel this way yeah you're
not crazy and um
yeah hey tracy you know what that's just
something that you say that john because
he has been saying that i need to go to
a psychiatrist
yes because there's no reason why i
should be unhappy with my life because
he provides me with all these
things except for don't ask for
except for meaning he tells you what
you're gonna like and what you're gonna
love and what you need and then he
provides that
without giving you any input on the
things that you want and need
and you're living somebody else's life
it is correct just like we all um
we all got by no we didn't all people
got biden checks
they didn't get value and purpose right
it's very similar
right you're not crazy it's the
gaslighter special
when you say hey i'm not doing okay and
they say well you should probably go see
somebody
right yeah dave said it the right he was
he right on
you feel this way because it's true yeah
and i um i'm a very hard worker i'm very
frugal
you said you've been married three years
how old are you i'm 35. i'll see
he is 51. okay
yeah he's acting like a daddy yep
it's not just the year differentiation
you're acting like in a daughter slash
employee
yeah he's a wee bit overbearing don't
you think
i feel that like i am more of an
employee yeah
i wonder what would happen if you quit
um i have
i have threatened that in the future
i'm saying what would happen i think the
dynamic would change
it changes for a moment and then
you know he says all the right things
and then hold on
what do you get what are you getting
paid to be the
project coordinator administrative
assistant what do you make a year um
approximately like fifty thousand
dollars okay you can go find another
fifty thousand dollar job
yeah go find a different job go find a
different job
oh yeah absolutely and the thing that he
always says is that i am
spoiled and entitled because he pays all
the bills which he has
i don't care what he says anymore all of
a sudden what he says doesn't matter
i've heard enough of it yeah you don't
work for him anymore
now y'all have a chance to work on your
marriage because you're not you need to
go get a job somewhere else and get a
marriage counselor and if he won't go
go without him and let the marriage
counselor navigate you through
uh setting this guy up for one possible
chance to win
or two possible chances to win and then
this isn't going to go well yeah it's
already not going well yeah
i'm so sorry i'm heartbroken for you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
john somewhere around two percent of the
public should be institutionalized
probably probably higher than that
crazier than a bean so let me tell you
how crazy and there's nothing crazier
than a crazy christian either
so deborah from maryland calls at the
break won't go on the air and tells
kelly to tell you and i that we missed
the last call
that we screwed up the poor lady who's
being uh over who's dealing with an
overbearing out-of-control husband
and says that you and i are not very
christian because if we were real
christians we would have told the woman
to submit and she would be happy
this is what you call an idiot whoa
deborah you're an idiot we didn't miss
it you did
and people like you give christianity a
bad name when you misinterpret scripture
and you think that someone should live
in a toxic situation abuse is an abusive
husband
and you call that submission that's not
submission that's idiocy
wow was i unclear
i don't i don't fully understand what
you're talking about just thank you can
you help me
goodness gracious oh man well the
proof that there will always be a need
for your show
and mine the future mental health
practitioners of america thank you
wow that breaks my heart man yeah well i
mean
yeah you're yeah you want your daughter
in that no so
you she want her daughter in that no her
daughter walks in and is traded that way
you should just submit it i just want oh
cool wow
yeah as as as two guys who have
daughters who are
brilliant and intelligent and very
strong two guys who have wonderful
strong brilliant wives
kylie who are not overbearing and don't
tell us what to do but we're not
overbearing and tell them what to do we
like work as a team
yeah submit yourselves one to another
it should be a race to the bottom in
there that's the scripture thing yes
sir it's in the scriptures okay all
right we got to talk to these wonderful
people and let's change the subject and
go positive now
three two one christopher and ananda are
on the debt free stage ramsey solution
way to go
how much debt have you guys paid off
we've paid off a hundred and ten
thousand dollars
all right how long did that take 19
months good for you
and your range of income we had a decent
shovel we started at
180 185 and now we're north of 200 just
north of cool what do y'all do for a
living
i am a cloud i.t engineer i bet you are
and
i'm a lutheran school principal
wonderful
wow cool where do you all live we're
just outside of st louis o'fallon
illinois
yeah okay wonderful yeah so good to have
you guys
it's good to be here dave yeah very very
well done how much uh
what was this hundred and ten thousand
in debt um all the usual stuff
i had about 60 some thousand in student
loans
uh and we had the cars and we had the
credit cards
we had a little bit of medical in there
too uh just the gambit you know
very cool yeah good good so you're kind
of normal we're very normal how long
y'all been married
oh it'll be 16 years on friday so what
was the wake up call
19 months ago oh gosh well there we had
lots of red flags lots of warning signs
the one that finally got to us was we
sat down with uh
one of our churches uh financial
planners for estate giving
you know in the future thinking about
that stuff and we realized when we did
all of the paperwork and
the balancing of the the pros and the
cause and the the plus and the minuses
we had nothing really to give
nothing to give other than life
insurance yeah your assets and
liabilities equal
zero zero we're broke no net worth
that's right that's right
so it was kind of a a pointless thing to
go through
getting all this together and not having
anything to leave anybody it was a
wake-up call
that was a wake-up call we wanted to do
something different better for us
better for our kids and and change the
family tree good for you guys
very neat yeah that's wonderful so what
did you do
well uh shortly after that we also had a
a
small vacation kind of an extended
weekend to kansas city and we we had to
really pare that down because we had no
money again back to the no money thing
and uh those two things kind of hit us
at the same time and
and i started watching uh your youtube
videos
youtube got me over to dave ramsey
uh trying to find answers to how to fix
this and and uh
countless hours spent watching that and
then listening to the podcast
and and then i totaled my makeover read
the book
and talked to ananda about it and
yeah we went through um we did the
financial piece university we did it on
our own at home yeah
went through the first two steps
together uh watched the videos and read
through the book and
um did those things got the every dollar
app and we were really
um you know very religious about paying
attention to that and
making sure that we knew where every
dollar was going and planning it out
and um yeah so we we were able to do
uh all of that debt payoff but also do a
lot of other things too that we
didn't even really think about doing for
example we were able to cash flow a
master's degree for me
in that 19 months while we were also
paying off the debt so good for you
yeah it just about got intentional huh
yeah being smart
and prioritizing and making good choices
i called into the show uh later of last
uh of 2019.
uh-oh was that nice to you well no you
shouldn't have been i
we we were we were uh doing okay enough
to be
extremely done with our money and and
that was the kick in the pants that that
i needed to realize that hey we're we're
squandering
i wasn't you were at work squandering
the resources that god's
god's provided for us have blessed us
with and and uh it really doesn't matter
how big or how small those resources are
you can squander
two pennies if you're if you're done
with money and and so we had to get
smart with money and
you helped us along that way so well you
know you know i was only mean to you
because i love you yeah i know it
i know it's
you know you've got to make some choices
when you have to curb a vacation to
kansas short
that's when you look in the mirror and
say that's right we should probably make
some changes yep
we live in the midwest and we went to
the midwest for vacation
incredible that's right and i love the
the the school principal telling us all
we should make
we should make good choices such a
principle
so what do you tell people now that you
did this that the key to getting out of
debt is
i know for me i actually tell a lot of
the teachers that i work with
at our school and our church has um
sponsored this program before and run
the classes through the church too but
i do tell people it's actually easier
than you think that it will be
um i felt like it was i know my husband
had to pull me along a little bit
at the beginning um he and i are both
very strong personalities
and um so that was tricky to start with
at the beginning to figure out
um you know who was going to sort of
take the reins and lead but so you
weren't like submissive
nothing i don't struggle with that
he does but you don't for those of you
listening she is
ringing her hands awesome
i figured that out real early i love it
but no i think i tell people that it's a
lot it's a lot easier than you think and
that
um you know for us too it's about what
we can do
in a short amount of time so that for
the long
future we're able to live and give like
nobody else live like no one else yeah
and you've changed
the trajectory of their life yeah good
for you guys
the kiddos over there well i'll tell you
this about them too so my husband bring
them
up listen to the you guys come up we
would um listen to the podcast
in his car with the boys all the time
when he took him to school and picked
him up from school
and there was one day i hadn't listened
to the show and there was one day in the
back seat of the car that these two
said uh welcome to the dave ramsey show
where dead is dumb and cash is king and
they could do the whole
opener opener that's awesome
they know when you ask them how they're
doing they say better than i deserve
i like these guys i like these guys what
are their names and ages so this is
lucas and he's
10 and jonah is eight and micah
is two oh good-looking man that's very
good very good
well well done you guys we're very proud
of you we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you to take you into the
next
uh chapter of your story definitely
leaving a legacy for these young guys
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to somebody who
helped you and you can give away a copy
to
someone else and pay it forward so very
very very well done i'm so proud of you
guys
thank you excellent excellent work all
right christopher and ananda lucas
jonah and mike of saint louis 110 000
paid off in 19
months making 180 to 200. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
[Applause]
love it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 5 16
come to me all you
who are weary and burdened and i will
give you rest
elizabeth elliott said one of the thing
of
one thing i am perfectly sure god's
story never ends
with ashes our question of the day comes
from the good people at blinds.com you
can find out for yourself why they are
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best possible
deal two months ago
today's question comes from alicia in
arkansas man this is a good one
two months ago we started on the baby
steps my husband made a budget and i'm
sticking to it
there isn't much wiggle room to lower
the budget as we have three children
my husband works two jobs from 6 30 a.m
to 12 30 a.m
i have a day job where i can bring our
two youngest children so we don't have
child care costs
my husband thinks that if i was truly on
board with getting out of debt
i'd get a second job caring for our
children and home is
already a full-time job and i can't be
away from home as many hours as he is
could i please have some guidance as to
what is realistic for me to do
can i tell you when i first read this
you know what it sounds like
sounds like an exhausted dad and an
exhausted husband
and who's i feel stuck feels stuck and
so he's getting this comparative
sacrifice game
i'm sacrificing more than you so my
sacrifice is more valuable than yours
and
man that's just a it's an exhausted
person who's out of steam and out of gas
and needs to take a break for a second
before everything just burns down
that's hard yeah there's one of two
things going on in the math there
yeah both of which are causing stuck or
either of which is called
causing stuck uh thing one is the income
is very low
yep even though he's working like crazy
he's not making any money okay
and so there's not enough income to just
keep the wolf away from the door so to
speak
um if that's the case you have a career
ken coleman moment here you need to be
thinking about working smarter not
harder and i know that's cliche but you
probably need to not make minimum
freaking wage and work 800 hours
you cannot get ahead doing that so
you've got to do something where you
make more
money if that's the case the other
possible thing is you're making plenty
of money
but you're sitting on two 45 000 cars
with 800
payments and you're suggesting that she
go do this instead of selling these
stupid butt cars you have
or this house you bought that you can't
afford the house payment is 50
of your take-home pay and you need to
sell the stinking house
uh something is in the log jam here and
you know the old
lumberjacks in the old days my
great-great-grandfather
david l the first was a owned a lumber
company back in the turn of the century
and they would cut timber in kentucky or
uh eastern tennessee or western north
carolina and they would
uh the huge logs they put them in the
river and that's how they transported
them
there were no big trucks and they'd
float them and they'd ride them
and poke them and if the river had a
horseshoe bin it hit the corner
those logs would would pile up and
that's called a
log jam jam yeah that's the name yeah
you know how they fix the log jam
throw dynamite in the middle of it blow
it up
and then the thing is you know blow some
of them out and they start flowing
around again
so you throw dynamite in the middle of a
log jams how you fix it and so when
you've got a mathematical log jam you
got to blow it up yeah you gotta sell
the house you gotta sell the cars you
gotta sell everything in sight yep
and so either you've got a bunch of
things around there that the payments on
you can't afford
or you have an income issue it might be
a little of both but it's probably
distinctly one or the other
what are the chances of a number three
that i've heard
throughout my career which is
a guy goes to work this is a
traditionally a guy goes to work and
works real hard
and thinks his wife is just
quote-unquote sitting around at home
she just gets to play with the kids all
day while i'm off x y and z and
it'd be nice if she got off her butt
every once in a while and went and did
it you know
yeah i run into that sometimes uh
but most of the time it's because he
doesn't think
that we can make it if she doesn't oh so
it's
it's it still goes back to a math
problem i mean most of the time
there's a sense of we're stuck in other
words let's say this
let's say okay he's working and she he
thinks she's kind of sitting on her butt
but he's making 300 000 a year and they
got no money problems yeah
that usually doesn't come up then right
he goes okay sit there and eat bon bons
you know i mean
you know and he's kind of doesn't that
maybe there's some respect issues or
something like that
but he's not like slamming his fist on
the kitchen table going once you go to
work you lazy
okay bomb right right you know he
doesn't that usually doesn't come up
there
where it comes up is when things are
tight yeah usually scary
usually i'm i'm scared i feel stuck i
feel hopeless
uh you know hope deferred makes the
heart
sick proverb says and so that that's
kind of what's going on so i
you know i'm with you i don't think this
is a bad guy i think he's a tired guy
or a stuck guy and he can't see his way
out and he's
going we got to do something and his
version of dynamite
is putting the wife out again yeah you
know go you know you're not making
enough i'm doing all i can do so you
gotta roll harder and i always want
somebody this reminds me my grandmother
used to tell me
she after she had her fourth kid she
always wanted to go back to work
and my granddad used to say we can't
afford you to go back to work because
child care costs were so expensive
and they've accelerated exponentially
since back then
and so i always want to model this out
too before you go get a second job
here's what's going to cost to put two
or three kids in daycare and
buy professional clothing and put the
car
on the road more and uh fatigue
food because i'm not here to cook there
you go um and
uh pre-prepared foods more expensive
than cooking from scratch
also not as good for you uh but it takes
more time
at home to cook prepared for i mean to
cook from scratch so
yeah there's tons of value that the home
economist
economically actually brings that's
exactly right so there's something about
you two need to get away for a minute
and just stop and say where are we
yeah where are we yeah he he's a
hard-working guy he's
not a bad guy and she's hard worker too
yeah he they both are but i mean she's
pretty pissed at him the way i agree
between the lines here oh yeah she
didn't like that
no she didn't like him calling her lazy
no yeah
and when i see somebody working full
time and taking two kids to work with
them they're not right
they're not she's not yeah they're in a
log jam i like that i like that analogy
dave sometimes you just got to throw
dynamite in it and say
we need to figure something out it's got
to blow up here because what we're doing
is not working keep doing the same thing
over and over again
definition of insanity expecting a
different result sophia's in
san antonio texas hi sophia how are you
hi how are you guys great how can we
help
so i'm a college student and in my
last few years of high school i was able
to save a pretty good amount of money
and so now i'm wondering how much
should i invest and how much should i
sort of hold on to
in savings uh what are you studying
i'm studying cyber
cool security you are going to make so
much money
[Laughter]
i'm so proud of you when you say you're
going to graduate
i'm going to graduate in three years
cool are you going to come work for us
come on sophia actually i'm in
air force rotc ah i actually
have a scholarship there very good okay
good for you so
how long uh how long will you be in the
in the service
at least four years after school but i
plan to serve longer
okay good for you thank you for your
service thank you for your thank you for
how bright you are and
and mature you are way beyond your years
so here's the thing i usually tell
people
is the the main investment we need to
make the most
return mathematically on investment the
most roi
you can get return on investment is
investing in this
wonderful product called sophia studying
cyber security
that completing that degree a hundred
percent on time
debt-free no stress pile of money in the
bank when you do it
is more valuable than the money you
might make on a mutual fund if you tried
to invest some of the money
and then ended up messing around and
getting a student loan because something
bad happened to your money
right literally the actual math
money you will make in the field of
study you're in is way more
than you're gonna make on a mutual fund
so
wait until you graduate to start your
investing you'll be just fine you're
gonna be doing great
i would just pile up a big old pile of
cash and when you graduate you've got
all kinds of options with that cash all
kinds of things you can do with that
cash then
and and you can get out and so
you know john in a world where everybody
hates colleges and universities now
based on how expensive they are in this
epic student loan crisis with our
borrowed future
podcast we still believe in
higher education when you study
something that's usable yeah
and when you can be intentional and pay
for it yeah
and then she's did all of the above very
very bright very bright
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to james childs
our producer kelly daniel our associate
producer and
phone screener i am dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you